[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in uh madame odio here's uh
mayam bialik the jeopardy guest host
talking about matt
matt emodio with 43 800 did you say duck
bill platypus
yes you did and what was your wager
seven thousand dollars for a total of
fifty thousand eight hundred dollars you
are our jeopardy champion matt with a
38-day total of one million five hundred
eighteen thousand six hundred one
dollars what a fantastic week well
played congratulations
and uh matt joins us now 38 consecutive
wins and you won over 1.5 million
dollars what's the number one question
you get on the street matt ooh uh i get
a lot of who was your favorite host
because i just saw so many and who was
your favorite host and i give a terrible
answer every time they're all my
favorite can't have favorites
but the difference in the host and how
does that affect how you play the game
yeah you know it's actually not as big
of a factor as i expected because
there's so much that's the same on one
person is on the camera but there are a
lot of people floating around in the
background on stage and it really feels
similar no matter who's up there
how nervous were you extremely i'm also
kind of nervous right now yeah shaking a
little bit i don't perform that well
necessarily but but you have to perform
and you got to be quick and you got to
be you have clarity and i mean it's
people don't understand
like it's you're up there on stage two
other people trying to buzz in you're
trying to
look at the clue put it process it spit
it out in real time
i mean it's what's the toughest part for
you yeah there's so much going on i mean
one part that's frustrating is you know
so much and you press the buzzer and you
don't win and everybody thinks you don't
know it as a result and that's just so
frustrating but you got to focus on the
next question and just stay like laser
focused on the stuff that's ahead okay
give me the question the clue that is
still haunting you oh boy that's a tough
one uh so i bet a lot on a final
jeopardy um that was in my wheelhouse on
the declaration of independence i'm a
big american history guy and i lost uh
37 000 on a single question uh so that
one that one's still haunts me okay what
is the clue
oh boy i'm not gonna remember it uh
verbatim but it was asking for the
language the foreign language spoken
around uh philadelphia that was the
first language the document was printed
in oh okay mclovin went to dartmouth
which uh adam from philadelphia and he's
from philadelphia so yeah yes mclevin
you buzzed in i would guess german no no
you have to do it
oh my god i'm sorry i did it wrong yeah
yeah yeah i just see screwed up he's
screwed you just screwed up
yeah and what's the answer
well if he got it outright it would have
been correct oh
my god
just cost himself 37 grand right there
andrew yes wow i couldn't even get any
yell and i'm smarter than that look at
that but you beat yourself up after that
oh yeah absolutely and the tough part is
you tape a lot of episodes right in a
row and so i did that i lost a whole
bunch of money but i still won which
meant 15 minutes later i just started a
new game zero zero zero and had to be
ready to be at my best and what people
don't understand is and i'm gonna guess
you probably do five episodes a day
that's normally what alex trebek did and
it is grueling
not only when i hosted uh sports
jeopardy we did four episodes each day
and it's just like you do one take a
break change what you're gonna wear uh
the audience may stay for a couple of uh
shows and then they clear that out then
you have lunch and then you gotta come
back plus you gotta come up with
you know
fun things to say when you're
interviewed when you know the host walks
over goes and our defending champ
matamorio here so matt and then you're
like what can i say that i
it's 38 consecutive shows i'm a boring
person so i was worried about what i was
going to say my first day and then it
just kept going and going and going i i
was really just like asking friends is
there anything interesting left about me
okay but holes hours cocky
jennings is a know-it-all
how would you describe
what is matamodio
yeah so i i tried to have a more uh
laid-back persona than that um so i
think they're really like intimidating
and they create a barrier between the
average person and them and i think i'm
a lot more like the average person and
so i'm trying to convey that but is
there strategy though that holes howard
tried to dominate you yeah i mean not
you but he tried to dominate everything
like he would talk smack he would also
dominate everybody in the audience
watching i could just picture him trying
to intimidate but don't you want a piece
of those guys oh i mean i would love the
opportunity i'm sure they would wipe the
floor with me but it would be fun
ah
are you sandbagging here maybe a tiny
bit yeah all right so uh yeah it would
it would be fun uh to to actually see
what they're like in person too so you
have to have a persona on on camera and
i don't know if that's actually like
what they are
now you go to yale
and you're studying to get your phd
people there's a lot of smart people at
you
do they look at you like do they like
you or do they not like you well so they
at least don't show that they don't like
me so i don't know what they feel inside
i can picture there's a lot of like
swallowing of envy and jealousy
they're at least facially nice to me are
you a know-it-all like when in class
i got a lot of people i've heard from
throughout the years saying if anybody
was going to do this it was obviously
going to be you and uh i think that that
was kind of a statement of how i've
always been this way okay but how do you
prep
yeah so i just like having knowledge so
i i gather it all throughout my life i
think okay that would be something i can
impress somebody by knowing later on uh
like a current event now is in the news
but ten years later it's going to be a
super impressive pull from deep in my
memory but do you not have a social life
matt therefore you read wikipedia a lot
no you see it it augments the social
life uh it makes for me to have
i'm a good conversation for the right
type of person okay
now we said that you could pick a
category by the way what was the
toughest category that you had on
jeopardy oh there's so much uh pop
culture celebrity stuff oh yeah you
don't do pop culture i mean i like some
tv and movies but they ask about people
who i don't know why they're famous uh
and i have to know who they are they
just show their picture and then i don't
even know the name of the person when
somebody else does it do you know who
cardi b is
yes
um are you sure uh yes
i could identify that that is in fact a
person like if you just invented a fake
name there i would have uh identified it
but that that's the last thing i know
paul bring in cardi b
do you know who jennifer lopez is dating
now oh i thought you were just going to
ask me do i know who jennifer lopez is
and i was good with that but no i
i don't think it's a-rod right not
anymore it's ben affleck okay yeah
they're back together good to know but i
i can give you maybe
a couple hundred points there all right
here's some baseball oh i love basically
okay now
if you want to tap out and say you know
these are a little too tough then that's
okay oh no that's a challenge you just
took away my opportunity to do that
welcome to jeopardy i'm sorry he said
thank you thank you the new york
baseball giants called this their home
ballpark from 1891 to 1957.
i don't think you're going to get
questions out of me because uh i i'm not
forced to so i'm going to say polo okay
polar grounds what is so you don't want
to do what is no i barely wanted to do
it when i was on the show
okay
this major league franchise is the only
one to never have played in a world
series oh geez um
that's
rockies
no obviously 2007. um
i'd be buzzing you right i go oh sorry
yeah uh pod
padres we're 98 no i i don't know
seattle mariners who are the seattle
mariners
the this man is the only one in the 600
home run club to have never won an mvp
um
griffey
no
not in the 600 club okay
um
aaron aaron
hey karen
he won an mvp okay um well i'm gonna
name like all of the 600 club pretty
soon uh bonds obviously has a whole
bunch yeah maze has them this is this is
a nondescript guy
if he if you can a nondescript 600
homework yes
uh pujols
has um yep
um
a-rod ruth i i can't even name another i
think i got all of them in the 600 club
see if ken jennings wants to join us
pauline holzhower's already making his
way to the studio yeah
jim tomy oh my in my hometown cleveland
cleveland wow
i forgot about that
he hit two grand slams in one inning
um that's tatis tati's channel
all right senior right an instrument
also the 1987
mvp
world series mvp
and uh was that sax
oh
right so that was like what uh cardinals
twins or something um correct so who
would be the instrument i don't know a
dave violin
frank viola
dave
violin
okay
um
close the door win awards this relief
pitcher won the cy young and mvp in
1984. that's gotta be rally fingers no
no no no no no uh willie um
hernandez willie hernandez that's good
this manager once smoked a joint with
jimi hendrix uh probably more of them
than admit it actually
and he's a current manager
that one i have no idea dusty baker
dusty baker thinking maybe ron
washington ron washington
okay
uh family business
uh he is an active manager whose father
was a manager um um
well
tito's father was a player all right so
not i not that not frank kona not friend
kona um
so
[Music]
coaching in the family no i don't count
on anything aaron boone
oh really okay i knew they played it
yeah baboon yeah who did he manage bob
boone was uh kansas city okay can't say
royals i believe so uh here's your last
one the
oldest player to ever hit a home run in
a major league game um
franco
yeah that's great julio franco yeah you
did it oh man those are rough yeah
they're pretty good good times though
how many uh marriage proposals did you
get when you're on jeopardy um
too many to count seriously yeah well no
i mean i they're not serious i i uh they
weren't i i don't think so did you
follow up on any leads uh no um and so i
guess i'm afraid that they might be
serious otherwise i would have
yeah that was an unexpected part of the
whole celebrity yeah
like
you know you don't follow celebrities
but you became a celebrity i know so now
like the other version of me and the
bizarro world doesn't know who i am
that's tough to wrap your mind around
wait explain that right so like i'm a
celebrity which means the other version
of me who doesn't know celebrities
doesn't matter
don't show off with a phd i'm sorry it's
it's early in the morning you haven't
graduated yet with your phd that's right
that's right and do i to call you a
doctor when that happens uh no you see
i'm not not a huge fan of that um think
that the doctor should be like you know
the the life saving
okay and and so is jeopardy
reached out to get you and jennings and
whole hole tower no so i i do have a
tournament of champions upcoming uh so
so that's going to be my first uh uh
return so you have to graduate to
jennings in holeshower yeah i think so
yeah
um it's gonna i mean you have to like
prove yourself at each step of the way
could we sponsor you like a nascar
driver could we get like a dan patrick
show
shirt or something that you could wear
you know i like that i don't know
exactly what the dress code is i think
jerseys are acceptable uh like the shirt
the sleeveless basketball ones that
would be very good
got to show off the guns yeah wow
easy there you're gonna get more
marriage proposals there
or fewer yes uh matt congrats it was uh
it was great to watch and it was kind of
systematic you know you were methodical
in taking people down but you did it in
such a nice way i i tried to smile while
i was doing it but i also tried to bring
some money ball strategy in as well yeah
do it in a smart way and did you buy
anything you made over 1.5 million no i
i'm frugal uh so i i still have like a
broken air conditioning in my car and i
was gonna say like you made a lot of
money maybe fix it now but it's winter i
don't need air conditioning yeah you can
winter wait till the spring yeah wait
till the tournament of champions yeah
that's right only if i won enough though
yeah
uh what's it cost for yale a semester
yeah all right well so phd students get
a small stipend
which is nice uh so it it
i don't have to like
go
uh take a mortgage out i don't know if
you can do mortgages on education but
whatever that would be i don't have to
do it do you hate harvard
no you see i i didn't go here for
undergraduate and i think that a lot of
those rivalries but you hate michigan
my parents both went to michigan i went
to ohio state and so this is like the
the kind of uh um do you hate your
parents
no this is like the romeo and juliet
situation where uh like you're supposed
to hate it but you just don't
how about that
shakespeare's sports analogies don't get
those capulets is that is that involved
in this yeah i i don't know which one i
would be i pictured myself more as the
romeo but but that's okay yeah
uh it's great to see you thank you for
stopping in good luck at yale and um and
good luck with the tournament champion
thank you so much this is such fun
that's uh madame odio he's smarter than
you are 38 consecutive wins won over one
and a half million dollars on jeopardy